i was hoping for some guidance on how to
play the game
with a situation at work i work in in an
aerospace machine shop
i'm doing this apprenticeship to be a
machinist
mechanist machinistry this means that
i'm supposed to get specific types of
on-the-job training
with a certain set number of hours each
what's that number of hours each okay i
go to school one time we're going to
reroll this thing huh no no no no
are you going to roll with it
discern kind of what he's asking at the
end of the day anyway
set numbers normally you get a little
sensitive if you make some mistakes i'm
just going to take this from the top
well my whole life isn't one big mistake
so whatever come on
it's an expression anyway i go to school
once a week to supplement it
the problem is they won't give me any
work that fills those
designations i'm doing my best
at the menial paperwork they've had had
me on for a while without complaint
it's a real problem though when i'm
paying out of pocket for the tuition
that comes with the program every month
spent
not getting require required training
adds to the five years it takes to
complete the ojt on the shop training
how do i get them to move me where i'm
supposed to be do i just continue
to do the best at what they give me and
accept the loss
of time and money yeah so you remember
the book that i caught me of leadership
humble not passive
so this guy's being humble playing the
game hey i'll do the menial paperwork
i'll
i'll work these extra hours i'll do
these things that don't really help me
he's playing he's playing the game and
he's being humble right
but he's also it sounds like being
passive meaning
he needs to up his assertiveness to say
hey listen
hey hey boss i just want to let you know
i want to i put together this
spreadsheet of what i'm actually going
to get accomplished
and here's the things that i want to get
done and i know i'm trying to knock out
all the stuff and i'm here to support
the team
but i also need to get these things done
can you help me get these things
scheduled so that i can be more
value to you and the team
so yeah you build a relationship through
playing the game you build the
relationship by giving support wherever
you can
but at the same time that doesn't mean
that you just
roll over and never stand up for
yourself that's not what we're talking
about here
the difference is you're not building a
relationship just so you can take care
of yourself
right that's different that means i'm
just looking out for me
you're building a relationship so that
you can move down the right path which
by the way is going to make you more a
bigger asset to the team
so it's a win-win situation make sure
you build that relationship and then
talk to them about what it is you're
trying to get done
why you're trying to get it done and
that way we move forward
down the path and by the way if they're
like shut up and just do this paperwork
or shut up we're not going to help you
cool maybe we need to find a place that
has a little bit
better opportunity for me and i'll start
to float that out there
yeah humble not passive
i remember a long time ago you'd say uh
you you
this use this word efficient be more
efficient rather than make it easier for
me you know like even though they're
essentially the same thing in certain
circumstances where
it's like oh yeah this will make it
easier for me to become an asset kind of
thing
but for whatever reason maybe like just
the way that sounds well yeah it sounds
like you're looking out for yourself
and yeah yeah but if you say you can
it'll get me
to be a more valuable asset in a more
efficient way
who can say no to that because what
company doesn't want efficiency
no we want to take the hard road we want
to do things that don't make any sense
yeah we want to do things inefficiently
no
yes efficiency is important not only in
jiu jitsu
not only in judo
but in business in life